[Rires]
très très fraîche toi
tu as une peau de yaourt
je te jure j'ai envie de mettre ma
cuillère dedans
non mais je te jure que c'est Daniel
elle a une photo
je te rappelle
[Applaudissements]
au courant le 8 mars déjà c'est la
journée de la femme les deux il y a le
match retour Bayern - Paris
Saint-Germain et je suis sûr que le PSG
va gagner malgré sa défaite au match
aller mais ils vont gagner je vous le
dis ils vont gagner j'ai dit que si le
PSG perdit je dis merci le PSG perd donc
c'est ce qualifie pas de se qualifie pas
avec 8 buts des cas je passerai
je passerai la nuit avec Daniel
une nuit d'amour après d'amour il n'y
aura papa dans grand-maman
[Applaudissements]
est enceinte tu seras bien dalle
mais bon
quand même je pose la question est-ce
que tu es d'accord
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est toi qui décide pour toi
calme-toi alors est-ce qu'on doit faire
ça chez toi est-ce qu'il y a ta mère à
côté
c'est pas possible
peut-être un peu plus vaste chez vous
[Musique]
c'est des idées reçues
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je vais te faire voyager
je peux te dire je vais te faire sortir
de Royan par contre tu vas voir des
ravioles
[Applaudissements]
c'est ça le pire la vérité c'est que moi
je suis à fond pour le PSG mais en fait
pourquoi j'ai fait ça parce que que le
PSG gagne si le PSG gagne je serai très
heureux parce que je serais content et
si le PSG perd je suis très heureux
aussi de te faire une expérience
si je peux aider la science quoi
du sexe
zodiaque avec moi
mon bonnet
surprise je t'ai vu twerker la dernière
fois
que vous attendez trop l'un de l'autre
vous pouvez être déçu
non non t'emmerde pas Daniel en tout cas
je serai au rendez-vous le 8 mars et
Daniel j'ai une question sérieuse à te
poser imaginons que le PSG ne se
qualifie pas qu'est-ce que tu fais ok
qu'est-ce qui commence à se matérialise
à la maison vous devez regarder le match
ensemble pardonnez-moi elle a raison
tout de suite
après le match pour avoir pardon
c'est vrai qu'elle a raison Géraldine
sur le clic-clac un petit Warner bleu
[Applaudissements]
vivement la mi-temps
est-ce que vous imaginez si le match se
termine au tir au but le stress
j'enlève toute Daniel en culotte c'est
moi en train de regarder
et je rappelle je rappelle que c'est
qu'il y a Mbappe son pénalty le Bayern
de Munich sera qualifié attention Kylian
Mbappé selon ce qu'il y a dans
et là tu imagines non mais t'imagines
vous avez remarqué que
vous avez tenté quoi la musique du
multiplex
[Rires]
c'est bon
je veux dire comme d'habitude ne faites
plus rien c'est ce que vous savez faire
de mieux
ensemble ça fera l'objet d'un
documentaire sur C8 alors
non non
comme le paddle
j'ai décidé de faire on va peut-être
faire un Tik Tok live
[Rires]